hello everyone my name is mary katherine
vaughan and i am a phd candidate at the
hospital for sick children and the
university of toronto in canada
today i'm happy to be giving a
presentation for lab roots on the
caliper initiative closing the gap
the learning objectives of my
presentation today are to discuss the
importance of age and sex specific
interpretation in blood tests in
children and adolescents
to introduce the canadian laboratory
initiative on pediatric reference
intervals and finally to discuss the
recent data caliper has published in
hopes to close the gap in the
availability of pediatric reference
standards for biomarkers of health and
disease
so pediatric laboratory medicine plays a
central role in health care
not only does the lab provide the
majority of objective medical data to
patient charts it also uses this data to
assist in the identification of risk
factors and symptoms
the diagnosis of disease
determining appropriate treatment
and also evaluating response to that
treatment as well
it is therefore essential that the blood
test results reported to patient charts
are accurate and accurately interpreted
as well
in pediatrics and in adolescents and
adults there are various ways to
interpret a blood test
firstly we have reference intervals
reference intervals can be defined as
health associated benchmarks used to
assist in clinical decision making
they are typically represented by the
2.5 and 95 7.5 percentiles in a healthy
reference distribution
and this is as for clsi or clinical
laboratory standard institute guidelines
as well as other governing bodies
in contrast we also have clinical
decision limits which serve as threshold
values where a flagging below or above
this value may indicate at risk of
significant disease or be specific for
diagnostic criteria of disease
a key example of this is hba1c
which is used in the diagnosis and
stratification of diabetes and
pre-diabetes routinely in both the
pediatric and adult population
now clsi states that when decision
limits are available and that they're
determined by national or worldwide
consensus
they should be used as opposed to
reference intervals
reference intervals really just
represent the normative range of blood
test results that can be expected in a
particular population while clinical
decision limits are often more
evidence-based for a specific disease
and can be of higher value in that case
such as in the diagnosis of various
heart diseases diabetes among others
unfortunately clinical decision limits
are not available for the majority of
laboratory tests and thus reference
intervals are commonly used and reported
to patient charts for test
interpretation
now there are various ways to calculate
a reference interval and they can be
divided into two different categories
the first category which is known to
most laboratory scientists is the direct
method
the direct method involves recruiting
healthy subjects for the sole purpose of
establishing a reference interval
the benefits of this approach is that it
is the gold standard by clsi and other
guidelines and it can be very robust
evidence-based and accurate as you are
asking a population that does not have
any underlying medical conditions and
are thus a true representation of a
healthy population
however the limitations to this approach
are that is very costly it does require
significant resources to be able to
recruit a healthy cohort and this is
particularly exacerbated in children and
adolescents
in contrast the indirect method is a
method for calculating reference
intervals that harnesses the power of
stored laboratory data that's located in
your lis system or in other patient
databases in order to create a reference
interval
now direct methods have been around or
rather indirect methods have been around
for a while but they've really been
getting traction in the past few years
due to the improvements in the
statistical models available to
laboratory scientists
the main benefit of course of the
indirect method is that it requires
basically no resources other than
expertise
time and access to a laboratory
information system database
however the limitations are that it does
require statistical methods to be able
to deconvolve a mixed population data
set including both healthy individuals
and patients and deconvolve that into an
only healthy distribution which can be
quite challenging based on more historic
techniques but we've seen a lot of
development in the past few years and
improvements in these techniques making
it feasible for laboratories to actually
use this method for the establishment of
reference intervals
however for the majority of my talk
today i will be focusing on the direct
method and how it applies to caliper and
our studies
now particularly in pediatrics there are
various challenges associated with test
result interpretation
firstly there are major gaps in
pediatric reference intervals and also
clinical decision limits and this is
largely due to the fact that there is a
high need for resources as well as
ethical limitations limiting sampling
from children and neonates
this can lead to inaccurate or erroneous
interpretation if an adult-based
reference interval is used to interpret
tests in pediatrics
it can also increase the risk of
misdiagnosis or inappropriate treatment
or lack thereof
and in addition it can increase stress
for patients and families which is quite
true in children in particular
in addition there is a lack of
standardization or harmonization of
assay methodology in laboratory medicine
and this is a problem for both
pediatrics and adults or an assay
methodologies differ across
manufacturers and as children visit
several medical centers due to the
increasing integration of healthcare
networks that may use different assays
or different systems or simply report
different reference intervals it can
lead to inconsistent patient management
and both these combined should be
regarded as a major source of laboratory
error affecting both patient care and
patient safety
now there are various covariates to
consider in pediatric test result
interpretation
the caliper team here at sickids likes
to say children are not small adults
indeed there are several physiological
processes that occur throughout growth
and development and a few are listed on
this slide including the fact that body
weight will double by six months of age
and triple by 12 months of age
body length also increases by 50 percent
in the first year of life we also see
major organ systems grow and mature from
birth to adolescence and this can
include sexual maturations that can
definitely impact pediatric biochemistry
and the analytes measured in blood tests
such as sex hormones liver enzymes among
others
therefore pediatric reference intervals
need to reflect differences in the
physiological function at different ages
sex ethnicity as well as bmi
and this can be quite challenging
because it means that a lot of different
reference intervals that are stratified
by these covariates are needed for
accurate test result interpretation and
these studies can be quite challenging
to do
one example of the need for pediatric
reference intervals and age and sex
specific interpretation in childhood and
adolescence is alp or alkaline
phosphatase which can be a marker of
liver as well as bone damage and disease
in children they have significantly
higher alp levels as compared to adults
if you look on the right hand of the
slide i'm showing a graph that we
published in a previous paper where we
have alp levels in the pediatric period
from 0 to 20 years of age on the x-axis
followed by adult alp levels up to 80
years of age
and we can clearly see that if you apply
a pediatric test result or rather an
adult reference standard for pediatric
testosterone interpretation you're going
to flag the majority of alp values as
high and this is concerning because it
can impact treatment lead to unnecessary
follow-up and potentially misdiagnoses
that require low alp such as
hypophosphatasia
so here's an example of how alp is used
in children it's relatively common for
primary care physicians to encounter
children with elevated alp levels and
it's therefore incredibly important that
we use age and sex specific reference
intervals to better reflect the
physiology throughout growth and
development in this case elevated alp
could be due to bone disease as well as
liver disease which can cause referral
to gas or enterology and for a primary
care physician it's important to
identify these elevations immediately
such that the patient can go through the
proper course of treatment and
identification of underlying conditions
so there are various initiatives that
have sought to seek this gap in
pediatric reference standards due to the
fact that we can see a clear need for
the need of age and sex specific test
interpretation and i've included a list
of some of the most prominent pediatric
reference interval initiatives around
the world including australia and new
zealand as well as the caliper
initiative here in canada
child x from the united states
the copenhagen initiative from denmark
as well as the kids initiative from
germany and the look initiative from
australia
all of these initiatives focus on
different age groups some from birth to
18 some focusing specifically from five
years of age and older and others doing
point estimates at 8 10 and 12 years of
age
in addition they differ slightly in
statistical methodology and also the
biomarkers studied with some focusing
more on cardiac and common blood
analytes and others focusing on
specialized testing
for the purpose of my presentation today
i'm going to be talking about the
caliper initiative which i have been
very grateful to be a part of throughout
my phd studies
so the caliper initiative was started
back in 2009 by clinical cabinets here
in canada it's currently led by dr cosro
adelie here at the hospital for sick
children in toronto but many canadian
laboratories have contributed over the
years leading to the success of this
initiative
to begin the caliper study has three
main objectives the first was to
determine the key covariate effect on
reference intervals for biochemical
parameters in healthy children and
adolescents
as well to develop a comprehensive
database of covariate stratified
reference intervals and finally to
disseminate study results to the
pediatric healthcare community worldwide
through novel knowledge translation
strategies to ensure that this data was
accessible not only to canadian
laboratories but also pediatric
institutions across the world
and in the past ten years caliper has
made significant strides to addressing
these objectives publishing several
articles and developing a unique
strategy and cohort recruitment
so the caliper strategy that we've
applied over the past 10 years is a
multi-stage approach to recruitment
followed by robust laboratory and
statistical analysis in alignment with
clsi or clinical laboratory standard
institute guidelines
i provided a brief flow chart here on
this slide but i will go in depth into
each of these steps that we have
undertaken in the past few years in
order to complete our studies
the first and most important part of
course is promotional recruitment and we
do this by engaging in partnerships with
community centers schools and other
institutions of the community
we therefore collect samples in the
community as well as here at the
hospital for sick children from the
siblings of patients and families
following sample collection the samples
are processed according to clsi
guidelines and stored in our biobank at
minus 80 degrees celsius
they then perform laboratory analysis
for several biomarkers of health and
disease and reference intervals are
established using a robust method as
recommended by clsi guidelines they are
then published in peer-reviewed journals
and finally uploaded to our online
database which i will speak about in a
moment
so in terms of our recruitment process i
would say this is the most challenging
portion of the caliper initiative and we
have had success due to the great work
of caliber coordinators students and
volunteers as well as our community
partnerships
today caliper has established
partnerships with over 200 community
organizations here in canada including
schools recreational centers arts
festivals as well as various
extracurricular activities
i'm providing a few images here on my
slide of past caliper participants of
course prior to the coven 19 pandemic
where we see these participants actually
participate at their local school and
various other community centers they're
able to do this by signing consent prior
with their parents completing health
questionnaires and then donating a blood
sample at their school where we bring a
small team of trained to kids staff
including nurses and phlebotomists
an important aspect of caliper is that
in contrast to other studies caliper
uses healthy community children and
therefore there is no underlying medical
conditions in these children adolescents
and they are not visiting the hospital
for any type of underlying comorbidity
this increases the robustness of the
database and also the value of health
associated values in a robust reference
database
the recruitment of these initiative has
led to the establishment of a biobank
that we house here in toronto and to
date we've collected samples for over 12
000 children in the past 10 years due to
the great work of our team
we've collected mostly serum and serum
separator tubes but we've also collected
whole blood and edta as well as plasma
in both edta and lithium heparin in
order to expand our study to more
specialized testing that require a
certain matrices
these samples range in age from birth to
adolescence and they are all associated
with health information that we obtained
from their health questionnaires
including family history health status
bmi and ethnicity
we use this health information to apply
inclusion and exclusion criteria our
main exclusion criteria will include the
use of prescribed medication
the appearance of chronic illness such
as diabetes or thyroid disease
the history of acute illness within
seven days of collection such as an
infection and we have a few other
metrics including pregnancy and other
prescribed or non-prescribed medications
following the application of inclusion
and exclusion criteria we store the
samples by centrifuging them and
alloquying them within eight hours of
collection and as i mentioned they're
all stored in our minus 80 biobank
following that they are sawed at room
temperature and they undergo laboratory
analysis for several biomarkers of
health and disease to date we've
actually
tested for over 200 biomarkers on
several analytical platforms
this is important to the caliper team to
make it a concerted effort rather to
establish reference standards for these
biomarkers on the analytical platforms
that are available here in canada and
worldwide to ensure that every pediatric
institution has the appropriate
reference standards for the laboratory
instrument and also their patient
population
so following laboratory analysis it is
actually time to establish the reference
interval and caliper established this
process that is in alignment with clsi
guidelines
i provided the flow chart here which
walks you through each step and i
encourage you to look at our caliper
white paper and critical reviews and
laboratory sciences that was published
in 2017
but i'll go through each step briefly
firstly we always visually inspect the
data and we mainly remove any extreme
outliers that do not fit the
distribution
we then test age and sex partitions
using the harris and void method and
this second step as demonstrated in the
flowchart is very important because for
some biomarkers such as alkaline
phosphatase we will need several age and
sex specific partitions however for
other markers such as calcium or sodium
that are very stable and tightly
regulated we won't necessarily need any
age and sex specific partitions so this
is an important step that is very
pediatric specific
we then go on to test each partition for
normality using qq plots as well as the
shapiro wilks test we remove outliers
using the tukey or adjusted 2p method
depending on the distribution
and following that we will establish
reference intervals either using the
non-parametric method or the robust
method of horn and push depending on the
sample size
so caliper has followed this strategy
from participant recruitment all the way
to physical statistical analysis in the
past 10 years and we've completed this
initiative in three phases i would say
due to the great work of past caliber
students coordinators and fellows as
well as clinical chemists
the first phases which i have not been
involved in was the initial studies
calper really wanted to cover cover your
bread and butter chemistry as well as
the key amino assays that are available
and regularly tested in pediatric
healthcare
institutions so initially there was an
initial publication published in
clinical chemistry in 2012 focusing on
proteins and enzymes in pediatrics as
well as lipids and other main
chemistries
this was then followed by a specialized
chemistry paper that focused on more
specialized techniques such as immune
markers alpha-1 anti-trypsin haptoglobin
and others
we also completed several studies on key
amino assays which initially involved an
endocrine paper that was published in
clinical chemistry in 2013 followed by
three follow-up papers in clinical
chemistry on fertility and sex hormones
vitamins and cancer markers
these initial publications were
completed on the abbott architect
platform which we use here at the
hospital for six children
but as i mentioned previously it was
important to the study team to ensure
that our data set was not specific to
one laboratory instrument and that it
was useful to laboratories using other
commonly
used analytical platforms
so the next step was to apply what we
found in the abbott architect to other
instruments
so this phase 2 um resulted in over 30
publications where we have analytical
specific reference intervals for each
test for chemistry as i demonstrated
here in this slide we applied
transference as for cilicide guidelines
and for immunoassays we completed new
studies by recruiting new children and
completing reference value studies for
over 300 to 600 participants on the five
main analytical platforms in use in
canada we've recently expanded to other
platforms as well i encourage you to
look at our caliper white paper to learn
more about these studies and the
statistical methodology applied
and the last phase that we are currently
working on is expanding the utility of
our database not only to include these
key biomarkers of health and disease but
also more specialized tests
and this is an initiative that for this
phase has been part of the initiative i
have been most involved in and i've
included some key examples of analytes
that we've currently been working on
including autoimmune disease markers
cytokines cardiac testing traits
elements point of care testing as well
as hematology and coagulation
so for the purpose of this presentation
i'll show you some preliminary and
published data on these specialized
studies so firstly as clinical chemists
here at the hospital for sick children
we mainly focused on chemistry and
immunoassays which use serum and plasma
however hematology parameters do require
age and sex specific stratification due
to puberty and the transition from fetal
to adult erythroporesis which can change
the reference value distributions for
both leukocytes erythrocytes as well as
platelet parameters
so we undertook a large study to
establish reference intervals for the
complete blood count which is a very
commonly ordered panel here in canada
and also across the world
hematology testing requires the
collection of fresh whole blood and
analysis within eight hours which had
previously limited many studies from
doing this in healthy children
however we were able to use the caliper
infrastructure to go into the community
collect these samples and bring them
back to the hospital for analysis within
eight hours we completed this in over
600 children and we have three
publications that are currently
available and i encourage you to go
check them out they're located here on
this slide we've established reference
intervals for the main cbc parameters
including the white blood cell count
platelet count hemoglobin and red blood
cell count that i've graphed here on
these slides
as well as over 30 research use only
parameters
another gap in pediatric reference
standards that we identified and wanted
to address is point of care testing
point-of-care testing is coming into
prominence in pediatric healthcare
institutions due to the low sample
volumes required and also the rapid test
turnaround time as well as improvements
in their accuracy in the past decade
so we wanted to use fresh whole blood
collected from the community to
establish reference standards for
critical care parameters including ph
po2 pco2 as well as the electrolytes and
various metabolites such as glucose and
lactate
we did this by actually bringing point
of care instruments in this case the
radiometer abl 90 as well as various
glucometers with us to the community to
complete testing at the point of
collection
and this data resulted in two
publications where reference standards
are established for 11 critical care
parameters and i encourage you to go
check out these publications to learn
more
the last example i have here is
unpublished data from a study we are
currently doing
trace elements and heavy metals serve
important roles in pediatric healthcare
by testing for nutritional deficiency
and also providing evidence for toxic
metal exposure
however there is very limited
information and particularly on
up-to-date analytical platforms that use
mass spectrometry for health associated
values in children and adolescents
so we went into the community and
collected whole blood and plasma using
royal blue top tubes as part of the
caliper initiative over 300 children
participated in this aspect of the
project and we analyzed the samples in
collaboration with london health
sciences as well as hamilton health
sciences which used high resolution mass
spectrometry and icpms respectively
reference intervals were then derived
for over 30 traits elements in heavy
metals and i've provided a few examples
on this slide
including selenium and zinc which are
essential trace elements
analyzed in plasma in this case and i've
also provided an example of silver here
analyzed in whole blood as a heavy metal
this study is currently ongoing and we
hope to have published data in the near
future to add to our database
so we wanted to make sure that all of
this data the caliper has published over
50 publications for over 200 biomarkers
of health and disease was accessible to
pediatric healthcare institutions
worldwide so we recently updated our
website which exists at
www.caliperproject.ca
i encourage you to take a look at it it
has new information for healthcare
professionals which includes information
on our currently ongoing studies and sub
studies as well as detailed information
as to how we calculate a reference
interval that can be useful for
healthcare practitioners
it also links to our online database
which serves as a consolidation of all
of our publications providing the actual
reference intervals as well as the
reference value distributions for every
test we have evaluated in caliper
if you access the database at
www.caliperproject.org
and you will go get to this interface if
you log in it is freely accessible you
can input the laboratory test of
interest in this case alanine
aminotransferase
the unit you're interested in your
laboratory platform and then it will
provide the reference intervals in these
tables and you can also look at the
scatter plots that we have derived on
that instrument to look at the dynamic
reference value distributions and also
can be helpful in longitudinally
monitoring patients
today the caliper database has actually
been used by over 5000 registered users
in over 100 countries globally and i
provided a map here where the blue dots
indicate the use of the caliper database
or logins and we can see that it truly
has a global reach which speaks to both
the gap that existed prior to caliber
and the utility of the database
we can also look at the laboratory
analytes that are most searched for on
the database and it's not surprising
that some of the markers that come up
first include tsh and free t4 markers of
thyroid function as well as alkaline
phosphatase a marker of liver damage and
ferritin a marker of iron deficiency and
also inflammation
this information is also available
through a mobile app which can be
downloaded free of charge by the apple
store as well as the google play store
it's essentially the same as the
database but you get a little bit more
information including the fact that you
can actually input the test result
you're interested in evaluating and
seeing where it lies across the
reference interval
these apps were designed and targeted to
community healthcare practitioners as
well as patients and families to ensure
easy accessibility to the caliper data
so with that caliper has published over
50 publications in high impact journals
leading to the development of a robust
database of up-to-date pediatric
reference standards using a clsi based
approach and also novel aspects
including community recruitment and
application to several specialized
biomarkers
the storage specimens in the caliper
biobank have enabled the continued
productivity of caliper amid the kova 19
pandemic which has been very encouraging
to see our initiative still push forward
and address gaps in this difficult time
and future work will focus on expanding
the utility of the caliber database to
include novel biomarkers as well as
additional analytical platforms and we
will continue to upload our online
database such that everyone can have
access to these data easily
however despite the main strides the
caliper has made in the past few years
there is one gap we'd still like to
address and particularly laboratory test
interpretation in pregnancy and the
neonatal period
briefly we know that the diagnosis
prognostication and monitoring of
maternal health and pregnancy really
relies on laboratory testing and i've
provided a graphic here from a recent
review we published in crcls
and you can see that some of the tests
located here such as the cbcs crp
cardiac markers are all used throughout
the standard of care and pregnancy to
identify complications that may impact
the health of both mother and child
it's therefore very important that we
have a comprehensive database of
reference standards in pregnancy
in addition i provided two examples of
physiological units that undergo main
changes throughout pregnancy which would
influence laboratory test results
located in green here i'm describing
some of the physiological changes in
liver function including increase in
amino acids as well as various full
change in triglycerides total
cholesterol as well as ldl and hdl which
is due to the fact that pregnancy can be
anabolic followed by catabolic and later
periods to support the growth and
nutrition of the fetus this can
influence laboratory test results and
therefore using an adult-based interval
reference interval rather for test
interpretation in pregnancy
is not appropriate in addition the same
thing can be said for thyroid hormones
where we see various dynamic changes in
thyroid binding globulin as well as free
t4 total t4 and tsh requiring
gestational age specific differences so
it was our goal to kind of apply what we
have done in caliper to a pregnant
population and we have therefore
established the caliper mother and child
initiative
this initiative focuses on two aims
firstly to develop reference intervals
in pregnancy in the postpartum and we
will use a similar approach to caliper
by recruiting individuals from the
community and testing them at each
trimester as well as the postpartum
period to establish a comprehensive
database of reference intervals
in addition we'd like to follow their
neonate and infant throughout the first
year of life to improve the robustness
of our evidence-based reference
intervals in the neonatal period for
caliber
so we hope that this data will be
available in the near future and we know
that laboratory investigations provide
objective data to physicians not only in
pediatrics but also in pregnancy and
that currently this can be compromised
by the lack of pediatric and
pregnancy-specific test result
interpretation guidelines and therefore
our initiative has really sought to
address these gaps i provided a few
examples today of how we have done this
our strategy and key publications that
have come out within the past year we
look forward to continuing this work
throughout the next few years to
continue to close the gap and update our
database as analytical platforms change
and new biomarkers are integrated into
clinical practice
with that i would like to thank the sick
kids caliber team particularly principal
investigator dr castro adelli as well as
various others clinical laboratory
students such as the u of t fellows who
circulate through here clinical chemist
laboratories here across canada who have
contributed as well as the many caliber
participants coordinators students and
volunteers so thank you very much and
please email me if you have any
questions at all